you need to put all of those attributes
together
and be able to make the deal happen so
as my boss once said look at the end i
give you a deal
you'll make it happen at the end
[Music]
ruby chen thank you so much for joining
in 20 minute leaders a good morning to
me good evening
to you how are you i am doing fine so
hopefully you know from the name you
were not envisioning
some sort of uh chinese uh lady from
singapore uh it is a bit misleading
so uh i get that a lot when people even
see me and and
expect to see a female instead of maybe
a jewish kid from
new york city which i am actually from
so
so what is the story behind the chen i
haven't met many jewish people from
brooklyn with the last name
chen so it depends who
asks so you know if it is you know
people that are close to me so it is
actually a
abbreviation of a longer jewish name but
i did have the opportunity
when working at amdocs which is a
multinational company
on the m a team we actually acquired a
company
uh in france that the main customer was
china mobile
okay so you know they needed to send
somebody to china
to explain that we will continue the
commitments of the company and
everything is good so who did they send
they sent the chinese guy of course of
course
you know was supposed to meet some
chinese executive from china mobile and
when i walked in he was like looking
wait a second where's that chinese lady
that i was supposed to meet so i
invented some family out in china it's a
uh not that much of a known fact but
during uh world war ii as you know the
uh
most of the uh borders were closed for
jewish people that wanted to
exit uh europe but actually one of the
countries that did have that brought us
open was actually china so there's
actually a chinese
uh jewish community that you know that
populated during
world war ii so i made up some chinese
family and you know we
when they ended up being far distant
cousins and you know from there the deal
went pretty well
i i think i think that's phenomenal
that's a phenomenal story
ruby we have a lot of things to talk
about from
running accelerators when they weren't
necessarily cool
all the way to doing corporate venture
capital which is also
a little bit of a new phenomena that
i've seen on the on the crazy uprising
in the past few years but you actually
again did that before it was cool
so i'm starting to see a pattern here of
identifying trends
and so there's a lot to there's a lot
for me to learn here
can you tell me a little bit about your
journey how do you get to
to to being director at these fantastic
companies
and then being on the wave of these
great
trends well
to the young audience here i would have
uh
like to say that there was a plan and a
scheme behind it
but it you know kind of happens by
accident right more often than not
so in my uh personal case uh coming from
new york city and being native you know
u.s speakers so
being here in israel that was kind of
like a unfair competitive advantage so
that's how i got into the
high-tech business to begin with it
started
by joining a
semi-governmental entity here in israel
that provided subsidized economic
services to startups
meaning lighting the business plans and
talking about marketing plans so you
know having that
uh native english uh back end you know
kind of helped me get into that
domain and uh i was working in a entity
that had a lot of startups that we
supported
and then i got the new a little bit of
the ecosystem
and you know talking to people and
getting to understand that and that's
how i got into my first
gig which was at a venture capital firm
here in israel called stage one ventures
it was a 35 million dollar fund the main
lp's
was uh besik which is the israeli quad
play
right telecommunication player i didn't
realize that they also
have an arm into venture capital this is
so interesting
hey hey dude i'm a bit ancient so i'm
talking about 20 years ago so you know
take everything in perspective but
unbelievable uh it was something that
did at the past and uh the
idea of the fund because it was a
relatively small fund
was to ask itself okay how do i maximize
the the capital commitment that i have
and at that time israel had and still
does
a uh program of technology incubators
which at the time
was owned and managed by the state of
israel
and wow you know they came to the
conclusion the state of israel that
managing an incubator isn't
probably one of the core competencies of
of a
of the state and that's why they wanted
to privatize it
and stage one when are we talking about
what here talking about 2001 2002
wow that's unbelievable about 20 years
ago
right time flies when you're having fun
man
so the idea was to use those people that
do not know
about this program it's a pretty
innovative program that the state of
israel
uh created in the mid 90s when there was
that large influx of russian immigrants
and instead of just having these people
do you know a low level
uh because they did not know the
language the
uh state wanted to
utilize these people and be able to
utilize the
technology capabilities that they have
so they created this
program wow that basically subsidized
the first
you know two years of rnd development
that the state of israel takes most of
the risk
associated with that so wow private
investor you put in
one dollar and the state gives you four
dollars back
up to a budget of about six hundred
thousand dollars which is
about a year and a half so
what the evolution of the program was is
that you had this large influx of of
russians but it was also open to other
types of entrepreneurs as well not only
ocean immigrants
uh but as i uh described previously the
state after a couple of years
understood it would be better to move it
to private hands
and that's why why is that so why what
was tell me a little bit about this this
in transition because
it's it's a really interesting piece of
the history you know today there must be
you know
dozens if not hundreds of incubators and
accelerators just in
just in israel right and just in tel
aviv and not even counting those in
jerusalem and the different areas
what was that process like for the
israeli
state is the government to run one of
the first incubators to start that trend
and then make that rational decision of
of moving it
to private hands
yeah so i think the state of israel was
able to identify
uh pretty amazingly
a market uh inefficiency and throughout
the years of the program even today
the way that the chief innovation office
of the state of israel looks at it
is to identify those market
inefficiencies that evolve
right over the years so at the beginning
saying okay look this early stage
of investments there's a gap here so
there are vcs that do investments but
they do not want to take that
high level of list so how do i identify
or create such a program that can
deal with that inefficiency and over the
years it has changed
so uh many years ago you know uh
the state of israel identified that
biotech has
been on the sub so they created a
program specifically for biotech
companies
and right and being always uh on top of
things trying to understand that
over the years as being the ceo of the
technology incubator
also in the city of tel aviv compared to
maybe a incubate in the north of
israel and all the south you can guess i
was on speed dial
of many of the different delegations
that were visiting here in israel that's
sure to understand and duplicate this
program and actually we had the
opportunity and many times actually to
visit
different countries europe asia
anything in between saying look we want
to try to duplicate this for our
ecosystem but the question is which is
the long conversation
that we don't have time to to go into
today is what is the special ingredients
that enabled
the israeli ecosystem to uh flourish
and to uh be what it is today the
thought of nation
so that's a long conversation but uh you
know anyone that you know wants to hear
more about that we can go into that into
detail so
i did the technology incubator thing at
the beginning uh
we were able to utilize bezick and play
with the basic labs which means you know
telecommunication
cyber security before that was cool as
well
different types of uh technologies uh
again we were talking about 20 years ago
right i believe 15 18 years ago yeah so
the best exit that we had actually was a
company we put in six hundred thousand
dollars a company
in the telecommunication authentication
space that was uh
called uh traffic's systems that was
acquired by
f5 for 130 million dollars wow a few
years after
so you know do do the math yourself you
understand you know from a 30 million
dollar fund
that sounds like a nice sell a ton on on
investment
100 so did that for for about four years
and then
being able to uh have experience
of of playing or being in interaction
with a large corporate like bezik to
identify new investments
and utilize that i was uh recruited by
a uh new york stock exchange
plated israeli company called amdocs am
docs which is a pretty big company
uh in israeli standards it's a
market cap is about 12 billion dollars
today they sell about uh
5 billion annually so what they do is
they provide software
uh solutions for telecommunication and
media companies
so think about the uh billing
of your mobile phone from 18 t at the
end of the month
that is being generated from a amdocs
billing system
when you crawl into a call center of a
verizon that also the back end the
software is a
and doc system more more often than not
and if you think about the network
itself you know the 3g
4g 5g all that software that manages the
different networks is also
managed by an andock system well amdux
at the time also
had a open innovation program and this
is again
talking 2007
2008. and they had a
small team that was supposed to interact
with the israeli ecosystem and
one program was to take a startup
technology
combine it with a amdoc solution create
a new offering and then sell it to an 18
t
onto a verizon rt mobile
they had another small team that also
had
the uh action item of when
uh having delegations such as
our vodafone visit is to match
between the israeli startups to
the requirements of the
telecommunication company
working very closely with the sales
teams of landlocked to be able to
identify
missing gaps and to understand what the
requirements are
so they were missing that small program
to get some skin in the game
so saying look if we're helping these
startups
develop you know these new technologies
products based on requirements and we're
also selling it for them why not
why not also the venture book right so
that's perfect that is what's called the
cbc
which is a cooperate venture capital uh
program so i was given the task okay go
figure it out and go
create something so today when you think
about cbcs there are hundreds if not
thousands of programs like that within
the region 1000 i think maybe
you know 80 percent of them have some
sort of program like that
but you know go back about uh 12 years
ago not
that common right at the time there
wasn't too many people to
uh study and to try to duplicate uh
what can be done so in israel we had uh
cisco which had a venture program we had
a motorola
which also one of the first ones ibm
which i've been here also for many years
but there weren't too many so how do you
put together
a uh investment charter meaning okay how
do you invest and what do you invest
who's the investment committee right so
typically you need to have a cfo because
she's she signs the check
at the end of the day but uh you have
you know someone from product you have
somebody from sales
do you create a fund with a dedicated
uh you know capital that is dedicated to
investments or does it come out of the
balance sheet
so all these questions you know were
kind of open with with
with me giving the task and go figure it
out and come up with something
i would like to share one uh anthony
please
of that process uh the ceo of amnox at
the time
his name was dov bahalav uh
he of course i wanted him on the
investment committee you always want the
ceo
right on the investment committee but
actually he he said something that you
know had a lot of sense and you know
over the years i even you know uh
believe it even more and what he had to
say
he said look if i'm on the investment
committee
everybody else will wait to listen what
i have to say and then make that
decision
it would be better for you not to have
me on the investment committee
and then you know you could have that
open discussion that you're looking for
the fine you know those
uh hidden gems that might you know not
might not come on to all radar
because it's not currently in in high
priority
but the intention of the program was
indeed to find
those types of uh you know companies
that are up and coming
that may be at a corporate culture you
might miss
so uh started doing that uh
made a lot of investments in the
mobility space the more famous ones is
uh
in the mobile advertising space a
company called moby
which was acquired by sentel for 340
million dollars
wow we invested in another company in
israel that did mobile payment
again i'm talking about 2008 2009
which was sold to jamal though the sim
manufacturer
we also had a company called pontus that
actually justified
the model of a cvc meaning
you invest in a company sometimes
because you're not
prepared to do the m a yet uh
so you say you know what let me put some
cash in i get some uh
ability to influence the company and
also if there is an acquisition
on the table then i you know i'm able to
manage that maybe more quickly
and be able to act on that so this
company called pontus which we
invested in in 2008 was eventually
acquired by andox which kind of
justifies
the mind right of why sometimes
so what it sounds to me is that the
difference with cbc is that cvc is
you know it is very similar to venture
capital in the sense that you're you
know you're buying equity into another
business say for various incentives but
you're introducing
another layer of complexity both because
of
the different interests that could arise
so when a regular vc invests
it's primarily for the financial returns
but when introducing
a corporate venture capital fund there's
also all
sorts of incentives one of those for
example is to be able to influence the
decision making
of a company which could potentially at
some point merge into yours and you want
to be able to either influence their
technology their roadmap
their financials their other customers
so it's it's it sounds like it it's very
complicated and i think it's really
inspiring that that you got to be there
and
and be really a pioneer from what it
sounds like
in a world where today like you're
mentioning almost every uh
fortune 1000 company has a has a venture
capital arm
yeah and it has evolved over the year
and this also could be a
101 session of a cvc so
over the years they have been developed
different flavors of types of cvcs so
just going fast forward with myself
moving from amdarks to another uh
corporate
called nice uh which is traded on the uh
nasdaq
alright market cap is about uh 12
billion today
it's a enterprise software company that
captures
unstructured data sets uh normalizes
them and finds insights
so it's a data analytics company where
the main
data source that they started was voice
so again
think about large b2c organizations uh
banks
telcos media companies uh so
when you call into one of those entities
you have that
annoying message at the beginning that
says this
call is now being recorded right
so 8 out of 10 times in north america
that would be a nice
system by capturing that
actual data and being able to do
speech to text right analytics emotion
detection
next best action for the call agent
itself there's a lot of value that is
hidden
in that so at that entity as well i was
at the club dev team
doing uh benches and m a's and the last
two years i actually uh established and
led
the hyundai uh motor company
wow adventure activity cnn tel aviv so
i've been doing cvcs for
12 years so it means a lot to be
said and to be you know discussed about
you know if you're a young guy that
wants to get into that space you know i
could
be glad you know give me a call you know
look me up i'll be glad to share some of
the insights
wonderful things that i've done
wonderful no ruby it sounds like there's
you know there's more hours and more of
content that we could that we could
talk about that would be fascinating
whether it's you know the israeli
ecosystem and then watching it
from the from the roots of it you know
20 years ago and
with bezek or and then moving on to cvcs
and seeing where that trend is going
today
to talking about mobility and enterprise
software there's endless more that we
could discuss but unfortunately
you know we do have only 20 minutes so i
have to ask you the last and most
important question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
yeah that's that's a nice question to
ask uh
i would start with uh curious so yeah
starting from telecom
and then doing enterprise software and
then auto attack so i guess i'm just
waiting for
that corporate that's in the biotech
space so i could feel that i've you know
checked all the boxes uh a deal maker
yeah so one of my previous bosses said
and this is again maybe something to the
younger audience uh how do you become
the best deal maker
so as my boss once said to me in a
larger audience
it's not because i'm the guy that knows
how to build the best excel
right for the financial model it's not
being the best technology guy that knows
how to
you know understand and and understand
the technology benefit
it's not the hr side which is also
highly
you know appreciated at the end because
it's a people thing if you acquire a
company
or you invest in a company it's a people
business right you need to put all of
those attributes together
and be able to to make the deal happen
so as my boss once said look at the end
i give you a deal
you'll make it happen at the end and i
think you know that's a very nice
compliment
they have and also you know for those
young people to think about that as well
uh so uh last but not least uh
i think connected so being part of this
ecosystem
not only the israeli ecosystem but the
cooperate
venture capital ecosystem for the last
20 years you get to know people and at
the end
you know you have that uh uh
ability to to be familiar with people
over the years and then when you do come
to them and come with ideas and want to
collaborate you know
based on that reputation that you're
able to build
uh for yourself over the years that you
know it's something that's very hard
to establish and it's very easy to lose
so you need to be very you know diligent
you know all those types of approaches
and who they approach and when so
being that connector i think also
something that is highly
uh important to to think about as well
and now we have the dubai uh ecosystem
as well that michael you just came back
from like right you could say a word or
two about
building bridges and being a guy that
could connect between the dots is
something that
right as a skilled set that you know i
think bill is required today
and i think that one of the one of the
most in like you mentioned i just
literally
12 hours ago got back from dubai this
will be
shared with our audience a few in a few
weeks but i
just got off the flight recently and and
i think one of the things that
fascinated me know me most
was understanding cultural differences
and really opening ourselves up to a
whole new world where
you know business is important but uh
connections and and human human
connections and trust
is at the forefront of these business
endeavors and i think that that is
something that i was very inspired by
this week
i got so used to you know the western
way of
of doing business and talking to each
other and forming relationships it's
very different
over there and i'm just starting to
learn how to do it and i can't
and and i'm 100 sure that you know
dubai and that part of the world is
going to be a major part of my
of my professional life and probably
that of many people in israel in the us
so i think that we we need to start from
the culture but i
definitely take to heart what you know
the insights from this talk and ruby i
really want to thank you for being so
generous with your time it was really
really wonderful
thank you for the inspiration and i have
a feeling we're going to have to do a
few more episodes
to really capture some of those other
insights that you were talking about
yeah we'll be glad to uh share you know
my insight so any of the young guys out
there listening or
ladies uh please wonderful lovely
reach out we'll be glad to share
wonderful
thank you very much ruby take care